et après à lire le retour dans ce
journal des résultats sport on est aussi
est bien content de retrouver mélanie
poquet pour sa chronique ou de leur
culture
bonsoir on savait gérer une exposition
des spectacles des ateliers à partir du
5 avril la commanderie à elancourt donne
carte blanche à un artiste david rolland
pour deux semaines d'art et oui david
rolland c'est le chorégraphe de la
compagnie du même nom et il invite à
plusieurs rendez-vous alors le premier
sera à découvrir dans la chapelle de la
commanderie
dominique leroy un artiste plasticien et
installera son jardin d'eau une
installation sonore des végétaux le
vendredi 2 avril david rolland laisse
place à l'un de ses danseurs benoît
canto un jeunes circassiens pour home
regardez j'ai toujours été fasciné par
la loi de l'effort inverse
vous essayez de rester à la surface de
l'eau
vous couler
quand vous essayez de couler vous
souhaitez
en fait ce que tu veux dire
ce qu'il a un sentiment de kigali entre
accepter que les choses se fassent et
chercher à vouloir tout contrôler
personnellement j'ai l'impression que
les choses elles s'assemblent
elles sont chez eux et chez vous il
s'agit d'ouvragés par fragments partent
alors d'autres chorégraphes et
interprètes de la compagnie seront
présents autour d'un thème d'une idée
construction et déconstruction et david
rolland propres proposera lui aussi des
oeuvres eh oui deux rendez vous plus
précisément alors la particularité de ce
chorégraphe c'est de créer de manière
participative les spectateurs deviennent
acteurs et danseurs avec les lecteurs
une chorégraphie collective qui vous
entraîne dans une sorte de balle une
surprise party est une appli manif une
déambulation autoguidés le spectateur
acteur aura un casque sur les oreilles
et suivra les instructions david rolland
l'avait réalisé une dans le quartier 17
mar d'elancourt en 2017 sont les images
que l'on voit c'était une découverte
artistique mais aussi historique et
cette fois encore il s'inspire du lieu
la commanderie ce qui m'a inspiré dans
dans ce lieu c'est bon à la fois bien
sûr son histoire les templiers
le fait que ça devienne une ferme puis
un lieu de résidence pour des
plasticiens et puis ce qui s'y fait
aujourd'hui grâce à ces quatre
départements missionnés sur la danse
les itinéraires poétique la science et
les arts visuels
alors david rolland a carte blanche
jusqu'au 22 avril et comme on avait
l'habitude pour tout savoir et ne rien
rater le programme est disponible sur le
site kiosque pons qui pointent est
fiable
merci mélanie retour pour le coup de
coeur retour également tout à l'heure
aux manettes de votre émission le 7-8
culture et